I'm Kristen Schaal oh that reminds me
Can I grab a prop sure I could get a
sitter so I had to bring my baby I hope
that doesn't mess with your emotions at
all or making it feel like you have to
hire me but um I need this job and this
is my audition right here
[Applause]
take Notaro great TIG why don't you read
one of the lines some men just want to
watch the world burn but one woman is
here to stop them great I do want to try
it a different way
yeah some men just want to watch the
work the one woman is here to stop them
probably one now where you really filled
with rage
some men just
hold buyer what are you doing oh I'm
just doing the scene where Batman and
Robin storm my Batcave snitch I'm in a
ditch Middleditch yeah are you here
reading for Batgirl
no no I think that I had a need down as
a reading for Cal the waiter in the
diner okay so we all done here
foster from Silence of the lamps I'm
sorry did you say lamps
don't you mean lambs I know movies
called did Hillary Swank read for this
yeah she did okay chief she bring an
Oscar in with her she did okay I can't
bring at night a hero is not measured by
what her power may be but by the courage
she shows in living and the warmth she
holds in her heart actually we're only
looking at women for this role um of
course this is the same [ __ ] I got
on oceans eight I bet sandy Bullock gets
this one too
[Applause]
named Maria Bamford and of course I am
upside down because I am a bat guys are
not into my choice alright ok did Jodie
Foster read for this yes
did she bring out that little night
statue she did yes
weird right yes how do you still make it
superhero movies I mean the world is on
fire the polar icecaps are the size of
basketball
Trump is putting babies in cages and
you're making Batgirl what her power may
be but by the courage I'm not getting
this Emma
you